[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici ce matinl Didier Grondin vient
livrer à la coopérative première récolte
de l'année 2 l de d'huile essentielle de
géranium soit 2 kg et 170 g précisément
d'essence de qualité qui lui aura
demandé beaucoup de travail ah oui ben
vraiment beaucoup même parce que pour
faire 2 l et dem d'essence nous il faut
nous comme nous dans notre endroit
l'essence n pas par rapport le manque de
chaleur n pas l'essence comme dans les
bars donc n obligé pour faire 1 L comme
ça faut au moins presque une journée une
journée de travail point en cuisson sans
compter le travail qu'on est avant la
coupe euh la plantation parce que un
géranium on coupe disons trois fois dans
l'année donc tous les après entre-temps
ben tous les 3 mois c'est l'entretien et
après car pour couper ben pour faire un
litre comme ça il faut nous coupe
facilement une bonne journée une journée
à deux ou trois
personnes après la pesée un échantillon
d'huile essentielle est prélevé afin
d'être analysé là il prend un petit
échantillon pour voir la qualité de
l'essence et puis pour voir chaque
producteur niveau deé qualité que chez
aut parce que pas toutes les pas toutes
les personnes le même niveau de qualité
donc c'est ça aussi fait notre force
c'est que après nous mélange toutes les
personnes là et après donne à N une
qualité que n' point du tout ailleurs là
il sont pas mais il sent bon
hein cette huile essentielle de qualité
Didier laa produit ici sur les hauteurs
de bras creux à la Pline des Cafres
depuis 2 ans il s'est lancé dans la
culture du ganium suivant ainsi les
traces de son
grand-père de qui
connait Roger tuin é un des plus gros
agriculteurs en ganium dans tampon voilà
en fait c'est plus pour remettre la
tradition en place et puis vu que sur
son terrain avait déjà les machines
installées et puis la famille est dedans
aussi a des amis il fait ça mais nous
fait ça en tant que point plaisir c'est
une passion voilà en même temps ben il
fait revivre tout ça aussi et en même
temps ben toutes ces petits enfants l'a
pas vu ce que lui quand lui lui éit en
train de faire ben n pas vu mais là
aujourdhui voir la possibilité de revoir
Didier cultive aujourd'hui une parcelle
d'environ un hectare du ganium Rosa
qu'il récolte et d'ici dans cet
alambique récupéré de toutes pièces et
qu'il a découvert sur le terrain presque
par hasard c'est vraiment le hasard même
parce que en fait nous cherchez un
endroit pour nous montre notre machine
et et ben moi tu es en train de
travailler là quand Mo en train de fou
la TER Mo la trouve Mo commence pas
trouver le l'avant l'avant il voyait un
mur avec un date dessus écrit 1962 mais
c'est là au fur et à mesure bon ben nous
l' fait comme des archéologues nous nous
des Vié nous nettoyé jusqu'à temp que
nous l' arrivé ben quand quand n é fini
démonter nous a vu que la machine était
vraiment nickel sans sans aucun défaut
rien le foyer rien n arrivé n pas just
la machine dedans et puis après nous la
monter une petite baraque dessus juste
pour la pluie quand quand nous distille
sinon tout l' éta déjà là comme
[Musique]
ça retour à la CAEB la coopérative
agricole des huiles essentielles de
Bourbon créée en 1962 reçoit aujourd'hui
de jeunes visiteurs au programme ce
matin-là découverte du principe de
l'hydrodistil
l'essence même de la coopérative donc
nous va utiliser un alambique pour
récupérer cette huile essentielle de la
plante donc pour ça il faut que faut
nous un alomque donc ici
a une marmite une marmite ici avec de
l'eau à l'intérieur et dessous le feu
donc le feu va faire bouir l'eau l'eau
va monter en vapeur là elle est en train
de commencer à monter en vapeur donc
c'est cette vapeur d'eau là que va
récupérer l'huile essentielle de la
plante les explications intéressantes de
notre guide se succèdent après avoir
chargé la marmite avec des feuilles de
citronnelle il faut à présent fermer et
assurer l'étanchéité du
chapitau ça c'est la méthode des anciens
ça ça c'est la méthode des anciens ça
mélanger un peu la terre un peu de
fumier pour faire le joint d' tanchéité
autour des alambiques et il fait
toujours hein et c'était simple et ça
fonctionnait très bien ah il
fonctionnait très bien parce que après
quand F mesure que ça chauffe ça ici
vient dur ça d donc ça fait un joint
d'étanchité
impeccable accumulé au sommet du vase
florentin au fur et à mesure de la
distillation l'huile essentielle sera
par la suite récupéré donc nous met ce
système là audessus d'un bouchon de
lierge pS Nous mett notceau de Cu dedans
et nous met ici et nous fait pression
ici et quand fait pression tu vois que
que il monte le niveau
z vous sentez est-ce que vous savez déjà
comment on appelle cette
plante déjà
vu dans mon Jard alors comment ça
s'appelle le qure épic de l'huile
essentielle aux plantes à parfum les
marmailles découvrent également toute la
richesse de la flore du jardin de la
CAEB comme ici le
Comba on peut aussi utiliser avec le
poisson ou éventuellement dans les
desserts par exemple une glace au
combava ou un au kombava ou un gâteau au
chocolat au
kombava mais il faut juste savoir doser
parce que si on en met trop c'est un
mangeable après voilà en fait nous c'est
plutôt un jardin de plantes aromatique
et médicinal donc on fait des visites
guidées tous les jour du lundi au
vendredi à 15h que soit pour les
touristes ou les écoles donc si c'est
les écoles c'est plutôt le matin donc là
il vont découvrir les plantes mais aussi
ben on en a tous pratiquement dans son
jardin donc il redécouvre un petit peu
les plantes qu'on utilisait avant que
soit pour la cuisine ou pour se soigner
et après c'est vrai que on les fait
sentir pour qu'il découvre les odeurs
aussi c'est vraiment une découverte
olfactive des plantes qu'on a dans notre
jardin on va soit les utiliser pour se
soigner ou éventuellement à l'utiliser
dans la cuisine pour certaines d'entre
elles mais c'est vrai que la plupart des
plantes qu'on a dans le jardin c'est
plutôt pour se
[Musique]
soigner